hi there i'm raine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and it's time for the sequel
reza reza the sequel is never as good as
the original this is never gonna work
this time i'm telling you this
this is the empire strikes back of
podcasts
right now
is it going to be the godfather 2 of
podcasts it's going to be the godfather
2 of pi okay okay okay a superior movie
okay let's give it a try time for the
second half of our conversation with rob
bell cue music
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
so last week listeners as you know we
started a conversation with
rob bell christian minister
professional heretic author of
many many books including love wins
about what happens when we die
and uh we just could not get enough of
our conversation uh it was interesting
because it went a long time and we kind
of noticed that it fell into kind of two
separate parts one was about
the kind of
scientific mysticism of consciousness
and souls and uh floating above a bus
over riverside drive and the second half
of the conversation got a little closer
tiptoed danced a little closer to some
some christian theology a little bit
more into heaven and hell
and it reminds me of the story uh so
growing up a young nerdy baha'i kid with
a older nerdy baha'i dad i remember when
these christians knocked on our door and
i don't remember what uh literature they
had but they were from the more
evangelical conservative side of things
and we would always invite those kind of
christians down to sit in our living
room and
my dad says you know what do you guys
believe about heaven and they said well
we believe that in the future uh out of
the there will be a rumbling the sky's
gonna crack open and a beautiful shining
city made of gold and silver is going to
float down and all of the believers are
going to be going up into this into this
city in the kingdom of heaven and
they're going to float away on the
kingdom of heaven and jesus will be
there with a trumpet etcetera it's very
specific yeah yeah a lot of yeah very a
lot of specifics uh now i know all
christians don't believe in this but
this particular group of people that
came to our house did in the late 70s
and then i remember my dad said well
we're baha'is and we believe something
similar and they were like oh yeah and
we're like yeah the sky splits open it
cracks open there's kind of a rumbling
but then out of the hole in the sky
falls bricks and mortar and hammers and
nails and planks and then a piece of
paper floats down and it says kingdom of
heaven
build it yourself kit ah
so i
admit that didn't go over so well but uh
but i think that's a little bit more
where rob is headed uh about creating
our own heaven and creating our own hell
and so dear listener without further ado
part two of our conversation with rob
bell
[Music]
i went to seminary and became a pastor
to church et cetera and in that world
there was a heaven and hell were spoken
of as things that happened when you die
uh i began
actually studying the bible and it's
like wait
the jewish
worldview there is no heaven there's no
jewish first off
like in the hebrew scriptures like what
happens when you die
they had the egyptians which are like
putting coins in people's eyes to get
across like what crazy so it doesn't
even say much
the bible as a whole it says almost show
the pit
maybe a few references and psalms
otherwise moses is talking to abraham
and we don't know how that works there's
a fog machine somewhere it's just so
what happened to me is
oh
and then when jesus i did i distinctly
remember
the day i came across the the person who
used the word hell the most was jesus
and when he uses it he uses this word
gehenna which means the valley of hinnam
the valley of hinam was the actual
valley on the southern side of the city
of jerusalem which was the garbage dump
it's kind of like the san fernando
valley
right only the south not the north side
yeah um and that when jesus talked about
hell he was talking about like the town
dump where stuff got tossed over the
wall down and that there was a fire
always going because you're burning the
gump sauce well the fire never goes out
you had wild dogs they were not
domesticated fighting over scraps of
food that would be the sound of gnashing
of teeth and that when jesus was talking
about heaven and hell he was talking
about very real conditions
that you create
here and now so when he was saying so
for a non-biblically literate person
i've read it but i don't have that much
uh deep knowledge when he was talk
referring to hell as gehenna he was kind
of saying do you want to live this life
a life of love and selflessness with me
and following my path or do you want to
go like live over in that [ __ ]
which stinks yes and then on another
level
awakening people to their capacities to
create these dimensions here and now so
when he's teaching his disciples to pray
your will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
he's locating the nexus of our capacity
in power
here and now in the kind of world we're
making and only speaks of heaven
as a realm where things are as they
should be and then you as a human being
are living your life in such a way as to
make heaven and earth the same place so
as opposed to escaping to go somewhere
else right it was always
about the creation of a new world right
here and right now so rob is talking
about and that switch
i've seen when that switch happens for
people everything changes so rob is
talking about a uh a real textual and
historical problem that
people who study
um the scriptures have which is that if
you
you know accept the sort of division of
the bible into the hebrew scriptures or
what's derogatory referred to as the old
testament and the new in the christian
scriptures or the new testament
there's a problem that occurs
sort of in the middle of those two texts
because
the hebrew scriptures
do not have a hell there is no there's
no such thing
as a place of eternal punishment there
isn't even really an afterlife though
well there is an afterlife but it's not
described as a heaven and hell dichotomy
like if you're really really good you
get to go and be in this place of
paradise and if you're really bad you
get punished and you go to this place of
eternal damnation that [ __ ] does not
exist basically like the camera goes
like the camera just goes out of focus
yeah in fact the best
that i've ever heard is a place of
shadows
yeah yeah yeah you become
it's this thing but it's
the shadow
version of that
and then the new testament starts and
from the very start of the new testament
from the you know gospel of mark
suddenly it's just assumed
that there is
a
a paradise and damnation now there's a a
lot of conversations about what the hell
happened like
what happened that caused this sudden
some people say exile which i'm sure
you're familiar with some people say
iran
iran was the problem like the persians
showed up and and and
who have a very clear duality a very
clear understanding of heaven and hell
of a good god and an evil god of
darkness and light that there are two
equal and opposing forces that there is
a god of good called mazda and a god of
evil called akrimon
the persians of course saved the jews
from exile uh gave them you know the
treasure back sent them back to their
homeland to rebuild the temple cyrus is
the the first and only non-jew who's
called messiah cyrus the great uh in in
the bible and so some scholars myself
included will say that oh these jews
were so affected by zoroastrianism that
they just accepted that cosmology and
created heaven and hell and etcetera
etcetera i think this is like can i
throw something all right so i'll see
something here
uh you also have this is uh this is
rabbi [ __ ] he's a good man he has
seven sons
and in the exile they lined him up yeah
with his sons and then in front of him
gouged out his seven son's eyes
slaughtered him then slaughtered him in
front of his wife
uh he was a good man did right
there's got to be
some way
this
there's got if this is just it we're
cosmically hosed
whatever the answer is so you're
absolutely right there's a psychological
as well as a political dimension
all shapes together
yes exactly whether it's a historical or
psychological or political it's a
construct because what we do know is
that for most of human history the
afterlife was envisioned as just a
version of this life you know maybe a
better version happy hunting grounds
yeah like if you were a slave in this
life you'd be a slave in the next life
you're a warrior in this life you'd be a
war whatever frustrated desire you can't
get met now exactly if you do the right
thing later yeah go for it and then
suddenly there's now this split right
the ultimate fork in the road yeah
absolutely where some of us go one way
and some of us go the other way and
that's where we're landing now right so
you got into some trouble
you are a heretic
um
because completely you went to christian
jail you went to christian jail you took
you saw this fork in the road and what
you said from not just a place of reason
because i think reason and logic had a
lot to do with how you came up with this
idea but also from a place of just
you know theology and and spirit said
wait that left turn doesn't make any
sense
and it's very actually very destructive
in the world right now yeah tell tell us
a little bit about that if just to kind
of well i noticed the people who talked
the most about heaven and hell when you
died didn't talk about hell on earth
right now
and uh even reading the gospels
jesus comes back again and again
to this world and the kind of world
we're making and
our power and capability to actually
shape things what does he say about us
within you the kingdom of god is here
yeah
so what there are some quotes uh around
that
um well first off when he's teaching his
disciples to pray
which is sort of the give us this day
our daily bread um
the idea
your will be done on earth as it is in
heaven was like way i mean i remember i
was like mid-20s like wait a second
uh he's not teaching them
how to get into heaven
at some level sort of sort of crude but
he's
teaching them how to bring heaven here
even if that's spatially
like oh
so he keeps speaking of these dominant
systems the roman system the religious
system subverting it with a new order
not based on those hierarchies so the
tax collector is hated is welcome to the
table um the leper who can't be touched
has touched like whatever system's been
put in place to push people to the edges
he always goes to the edges and brings
them back to the center again and again
and again and again so
it just turned everything upside down
for me this is about walking a path now
a friend of mine was in jerusalem
walking with a very very
uh well-known rabbi and said to him what
do you think happens when we die and the
rabbi said
oh that's not an important question
and then just kept walking like whoa
um
quintessential absolutism right there
absolutely absolutely so that rabbi
would say
why am i good because i'm supposed to be
good because there is no reward for my
goodness i'm gonna end up in the same
place as somebody who's not good
i'm going to be a good jew because
that's what god demands of me and i want
to do what god demands of me not because
i think he'll give me a lollipop
it's a better life now
at some level
christians uh baha'i
muslims you know that it's a completely
different viewpoint like no matter how
enlightened you may be uh or progressive
you may be in your thought fundamentally
there's a lollipop at the end of this
year yeah why am i good
not because i'm just supposed to be good
because that's what it means to love god
i'm good because when i die i don't want
to burn in hell
i i want you know that that like reward
it's all about reward and punishment and
what does that do to the story
when it's like uh because i had i wrote
a book about this and people would say
well then what's the point of being good
so
hell then in heaven became and i'd
always say
i love my wife kristen
um i didn't marry kristen and propose to
her by saying
i don't want to be with
phyllis you know i mean like that's like
that's the highest thing is i don't want
to be with her so will you
um yeah but i noticed how
deeply in people's almost like cellular
structure you don't want to go there do
you
which is which is such a complete
neurological shift from
is there a
joy
here now that's possible is there a life
and a vitality and a is there a hum is
there a sacred hum built into the thing
that i could actually take part in
that's a completely different set of
questions i also noticed
uh the roman caesar
mince these coins caesar is lord
peace through victory and the roman
empire from everything from england to
india just flattens everything in its
path and what's fascinating to me about
the roman empire's military slogans is
peace through victory which is yeah it's
peaceful because everybody who is
against you is dead right so
as i began to see what this first
century
itinerant jewish rabbi is doing is there
was this larger thing happening in the
world which was this dominant military
machine the world had never seen
anything like this before and the
slogans won a huge slogan was caesar as
lord
and so caesar would conquer a new land
and then caesar would return to rome and
announce i've conquered a new land which
means i can tax some people to build a
bigger and then he would send out news
of his new victory and that was called a
eu
angelian which means in greek a good
news or a good word that the word means
it's where we get the word evangelical
so so the word evangelical was a first
century
roman military announcement of we've
conquered another land and the way that
we do that is we go into that land
submit to us we'll tax you you'll be
citizens and all the benefits if you
don't we have this thing that we've
perfected called an execution stake yeah
and like you have uh mary magdalene's
from magdala i want to say that 3 000
jews were crucified at magdalena i mean
you have a lot of historic evidence that
they used crucifixion stick and they
worked really well
folks cometier is the most delicious
coffee that's brewed better through
science that's right science it's frozen
pre-brewed coffee and pocket sized
recyclable capsules and then you take
them out of your freezer you melt them
you add hot water to it no equipment
needed and you are about a minute away
from barista quality coffee and lattes
and i am not joking here my whole entire
household is obsessed with coma tear
i've i've gotten to the point where i
have to literally hide these capsules
from my wife it is so easy there is no
muss there's no fuss there's no grinds
there's no
machines that break and get clogged you
take out your frozen little capsule you
add hot water that's it we have got a
special offer just for our listener so
it's a very limited time but you can get
20 bucks off your first order that's
about 10 free cups and of course
shipping is always free but only when
you visit
slash
commenter.com
20 that's c-o-m-e-t-e-e-r
cometier
slash milkshake 20. you know i was a
little skeptical about coma tear at
first i mean it's brewed coffee you melt
to make that kind of defies reason but
it's truly one of the best if not the
best tasting cups of coffee i've ever
had and if you like coffee at all this
is a taste to believe product that's
cometeer.com milkshake20 to save 20
on your first order a new day has
arrived on earth for coffee that's
comateer.com
milkshake20.
do you identify as cryptocurious
if you've thought about entering the
world of cryptocurrency but felt a
little overwhelmed coinbase makes
learning to buy and sell simple
look i know how you feel all right
cryptocurrency is like this weird like
secret exclusive club but
coinbase believes that everyone
everywhere should be able to get into
the door whether you've been trading for
years like rain or you're just getting
started like me coinbase can help
coinbase makes it quick and easy to
start your own portfolio
and learn how to grade like a pro
if you've been looking to level up your
financial portfolio it's always good to
diversify right back by the world's
leading investors coinbase keeps your
portfolio safe and secure while adding
crypto into your mix
coinbase offers a trusted and easy to
use platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and they make them accessible to
everyone for a limited time new users
could get ten dollars in free bitcoin
when you sign up today at coinbase.com
milkshake sign up at coinbase.com
milkshake for ten dollars in free
bitcoin this offer is for a limited time
only so be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com slash milkshake
so you have jesus is lord and the good
news as a kind of a revolutionary actor
this goes with your this rage against
the machine
with your book is like this yeah this
kind of subversive that's a truly
revolutionary act
um and wait a minute this this humble
day laborer from the north of palestine
is lord
and this is the real good news and it
must have just blown some gas so you can
see why people like rez and i who have
sort of read some of this the idea in in
present modern culture
that christian is aligned
with american
political right empire
is insanity it's
absolute insanity i i literally had
periods where i was like because i
started a church and i got really big
do i just leave this thing
because i am
reading these texts
talking these ideas so then the jesus
question becomes who is lord jesus or
caesar in some ways the new testament
that's the question these first jesus
people are asking the world how do you
make a better world do you make a better
world through coercive military violence
you bomb us we bomb you drone strikes or
is the world made better through
sacrificial love
so the eucharist the communion table
began
we have this table caesar throws out
bread but we have a table
where we have this meal we go around
make sure everybody's rent is paid um
who's making a better world how is the
world made better which to me is it's
still the question yeah which is why the
current state and so for me as a pastor
in a whatever christian church it was
like
i either
i just walk away from this all the way
or i double down on
this thing is so off the rails
it's so far from its origins it has so
bastardized its roots
so
we know um what happened to you when
when you started preaching this new
idea of the gospel
my question
touches on
the responses that you got the sort of
visceral responses of fear like well
then why why shouldn't i point out my
wife what
right
okay but
more importantly
the flip side of that which is so so
much a part of your your message and why
i would say that you've become you know
even
bigger and i think more people have have
gravitated towards you than when you
were in that admittedly very large
church um is that
suddenly
when
that
ax isn't above your head any longer yes
the response isn't
uh freedom from morality as as i think
that a lot of people
right right right the response is
instead
actual freedom is it not like yeah right
that's what happens right right what
happens to a christian
when heaven and hell
are no longer on the table in the sort
of traditional
dichotomous yeah first i would point out
that
what i kept experiencing is this is in
the water stream of western culture
so even the idea of who's a christian or
christians or not
um some of these ideas i are actually at
this point cultural they're just in
in the system so the person who i never
go to church i don't believe any of that
would be like
even i'd notice people go like i never
go to church and if i go to church like
the lightning bolts to come or the roof
of cave and i'm like oh this is not a
religious thing this is a human thing at
some level secondly what i found
fascinating is how many people would say
to me i now understand my um suicidal
thoughts
what do you mean it's shocking how many
people would say
i was given a view that
billions of people are going to burn
forever in hell there's a fork and some
people go to heaven and some people go
to hell they were handed the church the
culture et cetera and then you give that
person let's say just one traumatic
event
i i began to see how many people these
ideas had shaped their view of the
universe these weren't religious views
these were what kind of universe are we
living in are we living in a universe
where if you don't say the right prayer
believe the right thing join the right
church you could burn in hell forever
that's a cosmological
statement and i noticed how many people
when i would begin to lay out
where these ideas of heaven and hell and
where some of this got all turned around
would go oh that's why something within
me wonders whether it's even worth it
is it wasn't just should i be good or
not or not cheat on my wife it went all
the way back to what is the point of
this thing if i might die and find out
that i
didn't say the right prayer
at the right time but how does that sync
up with this christian view that you can
be a shitty person your whole life but
if at the end of your life or on your
death bed or something like that you're
baptized or you repent
right right or you say please forgive me
jesus it's like lollipop it's just
dispensing lollipops early it just
becomes so random and arbitrary whatever
the [ __ ] you right but it's also the
core the whole point of salvation isn't
it like you have christianity without
that because you immediately have the
what's the point of being good okay now
we're into a whole different world so
like you said it makes you sort of your
brain hurts because you're like
okay we gotta go way way way this
question presents itself like it's way
far down the road we gotta go way way
earlier in the road to what do you think
we're doing here
what has been your experience of has
been generous been that horrible that
you that you have questions about
um
and uh what i also noticed when we
brought it to this moment is that it put
people well what happens when i die what
happens how does everything get sorted
out well
how about trust
that if you experience a goodness now it
all gets sorted out
isn't that um too yeah and faith greater
than a christian you are a faith that
there is a
goodness in yes the creative juice of
the universe and that there's a plan
of vision and i actually resolution
this
is a seismic shift from fear management
to faith and i actually think it
involves limbic like early reptile brain
you think about early brain development
is threat assessment um
and and if you can convince people
there's a threat you can get them to
vote for you you can
it's pr it's a pre-rational
and when i and uh
it's actually studying neurology like
oh when there is an existential threat
of you might die and get judged forever
well of course a bunch of other
discussions aren't
possible
that is major threat management but if
we can move beyond that too nothing can
separate you from the love of god if we
can move to faith trust
uh a generative goodness
at the heart of the universe
we're actually moving you to a different
part of your brain that can then put
itself in someone else's shoes it can
uh
hope imagination a lot of good art comes
from there but how do you how do you
marry the the wonderful metaphysical
science that you've been quoting yeah
and your christian belief when it comes
to the next world and so if there's a
new vision of of heaven and the
afterlife
how do you marry those two things they
all sit side by side first century
jewish people were working with the
images and metaphors they had
so
uh at that time
like when this first writer paul
writes a big chunk of the new testament
speaks of a reconciliation of all things
jesus talked about a renewal
the apostle peter talks about a
restoration renewal restoration
reconciliation
uh
and my experience
i they loved our words all i knew is
those visions
we're like well if everybody
had that anticipation and organized
their lives around that right now that's
a pretty great vision i don't know how
that works out um and immediately good
god the number of radio shows well what
about hitler
you know what i mean the people go to
this and
just [ __ ] everything up doesn't it um
so so that's why i sort of uh i'm not
hesitant but i just and everybody's
gonna get along in the end um
right now in the world that we're in a
sort of kumbaya all the parts and holes
all get together it's like
yeah but let me let me be a little tough
on you here rob because you're dodging
this question i'm getting to it i'm just
trying to do all the proper disclaimers
so that i don't just don't get in
trouble you don't get excommunicated
again oh that's already happened um so
that i don't so you don't say what
happens in the end and i say everybody
ends up on planet earth in their bodies
at the proper weight eating organic food
you see what i'm saying like you could
just charge into that and be people be
like really that's what you think that's
why i also tried to do like uh i tried
to step outside and go now in sort of
historic christian theology they would
speak of a new heaven or newest it's a
vision of a new play i'm trying to move
in around all these so that the dodge at
least has some purpose okay to it i also
go to
what's a vision of life
that you could orient yourself around
right now
that would fill you with some sense of
faith and hope and resilience might even
be contagious
and
this uh reconciliation restoration and
renewal
i could use that
in my own self we could use that
i think we all
use that so how does jesus do that how
does god fit into that when i was a kid
my parents would take us to church so i
would hear the jesus stories
and there's something about the stories
at a young age
that
invited me to trust
there's more going on here
we're going to be okay
um
it did something to me at some
heart
cellular level these stories imprinted
on me
a grace
you're kind of jacked up but you're it's
also good that you're here you're
talking about the story behind the story
yeah the story behind the something
happened to me in an early age it's it's
good to be human
it's good to be human and i'm fascinated
with how many people it's good to be
human
is a new
concept sometimes disruptive
sometimes it's like oxygen and they
realize they've been choking
the suffocate
it's good that we're here it's good that
we're human
how does it all i mean you have endless
metaphors for what happens to our the
ways that we've hurt each other the ways
that we've made a mess of things sins is
the big word um
i just something imprinted on me you're
okay grace
grace you're okay so follow this path
so i love that uh that's why i dodge
with something really complicated and
then something childlike and simple is
some days i need that and some days i
need
the other
[Music]
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really
really simple with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive there's busy schedules we don't
get enough sleep we don't get enough
exercise the environment work stress
i don't know covered maybe not eating
enough of the right foods all of these
things can leave us deficient in key
nutritional areas i love ag-1 by
athletic greens
truly do i have been using it since they
sent me the sample and i love it
one tasty scoop of ag-1 contains 75
vitamins minerals and whole-food-sourced
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving the special blend of high
quality bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop of ag-1 work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet it helps
support energy and focus it aids you
with your gut health and digestion and
it supports a healthy immune system join
the movement of athletes life leads
that's me moms dads rookies first timers
and well everyone in between taking
ownership of their daily health and
focusing on the nutritional products
they really need in the simplest manner
possible that's essentialist nutrition
and to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you an immune supporting
free one-year supply of vitamin d
i have mine right here and five free
travel packs with your first purchase if
you visit athleticgreens.com
milkshake today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
milkshake to take control of your health
and give ag-one a try have you looked in
the mirror recently i mean like really
looked in the mirror
that beard you grew out over the last
year you know it was a hot new thing for
you a little like pandemic experiment
and now it's just hot outside and you're
going out into the world and it's time
to tame that bad boy you know what i'm
saying rain harry's crafts high quality
long lasting blades and durable weighted
handles that make a close comfortable
shave quick and dare we say a little bit
enjoyable yes we dare say it and because
harry's insist that you shouldn't have
to choose between a great shave and a
fair price they just give you both
refill blades start as low as two bucks
easy decision you know what's even
easier new harry's customers get their
starter set which includes a five blade
razor weighted handle foaming shave gel
with aloe and a travel cover all of it
it's a 13 value for three bucks
i have been using harry's razors
for years yes i know i have a beard
right now folks but i gotta shave my
neck occasionally and the little stray
hairs on my cheek
i love the weighted handle of harry's
the blades are really sharp it's very
very convenient i highly recommend it
there's never been a better time to try
harry so go to harry's dot-com slash
milkshake to get their starter set for
just three bucks
it's 100 satisfaction guaranteed you got
nothing to lose go to harrys.com
milkshake right now and you can get the
special offer that's h-a-r-r-y-s
harry's dot com slash milkshake
[Music]
so
whatever it is you have no idea but it
involves some kind of meeting with the
divine and some kind of grace or
salvation not just for you but
ultimately for everyone
on the other side of that bus and you
know what i might be reading that right
and and and i do like that i do like
also uh the
the preservation of human will every
step of the way you don't
want to forgive this person who has
wronged you you don't want to
participate you do okay
yeah and what i love too is what we've
done in this conversation is that we
began with
that body getting hit with the bus
and then we're ending back with the body
it's this conversation about the
afterlife heaven hell what happens
i love that rob
took us from
that sort of
world of the spirit back to the material
but it's about it's about this it's
about the new earth it's about who we
are
the heaven and hell is right here like
jesus
said
the kingdom of god is here it's now
it's within you
it's not a thing
that will come after we all die it's now
it's here yeah
i love that
to me and this goes way back
to when i was a kid whatever's ultimate
it has to be material
that got like somehow imprinted on me
the mystery is born in bodies so like
floating above the bus and all that
to me
there's something about the body that's
integral to the whole thing and so many
people the word spiritual means
leave other than you know what i mean
it's it denigrates the material so many
expressions of spiritual get woo-woo
they get squishy they get
uh floating six inches above the earth
you're gonna die it's evacuation
theology when you die you leave this
place it's all gonna burn um
but to me if it's ultimate then it is
embodied
i mean music
sex food surfing like all the juice
which is why what happens then couldn't
there be
other rounds other dimensions that's
poppycock because it's like you ask the
baby let's go back to this metaphor you
go back to the baby in the womb
you we're going to go to a place
where there's martin scorsese movies
and the smell of lavender and there's
tacos yeah and the baby's going to be
like no
what why do i need all that conjecture
i'm fine right here i've got squishy
juice and i'm in a womb and i can hear
the boom of music outside i'm just fine
like
we can't comprehend that and there may
be an entire other way of being that i'm
not saying it's anti-body or anti right
real but it's some other blossoming into
it into some new space where there's
some version of surfing that's way
better look at the version of music the
baby has in the womb yeah compared to a
version of music we have when we're at a
radiohead concert right right that's why
my hands are up in the air because the
baby only has the baby's experience in
speculating and trying to imagine that's
just what i mean by the material is
whatever this is
and whatever's after it
it will
if it's better if it's more if it's more
expansive the baby can only talk about
it in these terms
it only has baby terms squishy mushy
you know what i mean
rob this has been amazing we need to let
you go one quick thing we do when we end
every interview is a lightning round of
life's big questions okay lightning
round when do you rob bell feel most
connected with the universe
on a wave
or eating tacos with my family
describe your soul in 10 words or less
insatiably curious
and laughing while limping
not bad
what is your biggest fear
that i missed my opportunity
what's one i don't even know what that
means i just know that that's the weird
language that comes up
what's one thing that you hate
being disrespected
me too
i [ __ ] hate that i throw myself into
this with everything i have yeah like
you
like
this has been a long
road of this is where the joy is giving
it everything i got
and
yeah
this is not turning into a lightning
round this is gonna this is gonna turn
into uh this next question the segway's
perfectly into what do you think is the
purpose of your life
to be free from the need for a purpose
what's one thing that you know for sure
that tomorrow does not have to be a
repeat of today
when was the last time you ugly cried
within two weeks
can you tell us about that any deets uh
grief
over an unresolved situation that's now
a decade
in the works and there's
nothing right now that i know of to do
so it just sits there unresolved
it's like the person who's not at the
party and there's nothing you can do
about it
and then you question that belief maybe
there is something i can do and just
keep coming back to i just have to sit
with this unresolved and my heart
can
barely take it
yeah
and then finally what is your life's big
question
is this all part of it
like
the pain the trump
the environmental degradati is
is this all part of some larger
integration that because i know from my
life the stuff i look back on that was a
mess i'm like where would i be without
that
so i know at a deep personal level if i
ask you
give me the four or five moments that
most affected who you are shaped you
formed you you would not tell me like i
went to
gulf coast the weather was pretty nice
you know what i mean i got a new pickup
truck no no you tell me loss pain
suffering you got fire you didn't get
that you didn't get that so i know at a
deeply intimate personal level when i
look back on the things
but i don't want to use the word
grateful but that is the word it's
counterintuitive
so then is this whole thing
that on a mega scale
and i can't even
fathom that and yet
that's what it looks like we're in a
three-dimensional soul-growing
laboratory thank you
yeah yeah yeah so is all this get
integrated because there's too much that
i don't know how that could ever be
integrated but i didn't know how it
could happen in my life
so it always makes for a better story
you're a dinner party there's some guy
at the table who's like i was pretty
good when i was young that i tried some
new stuff i was really good at that then
i branched out i was awesome at that get
that guy
but there's a lady who's like i walked
up hill both ways in the snow with bare
feet and i didn't like okay carol here
yeah forget wayne over there
so i just know how it works at like a
dinner party
um
you get knocked around and that's where
you find the grace
and the love and that's how that's what
makes the story good you brought a lot
of grace to this conversation and i
loved it i i had a blast robel thank you
so much
[Music]
well there you have it
two episodes on
what happens when this is all over
amazing what an incredible conversation
uh i love the way that he has
really revolutionized how one thinks
about christianity as a
for lack of a better word as a theology
as a as a philosophy as a as a way of
life as a life system yeah and he's
unapologetic about it like he's you know
he's not going to beat around the bush
he is a devout believer and the
arguments that he makes about heaven and
hell are in his view scripturally sound
and you know damn the consequences uh
if you would i love this thing he kept
saying about how in speaking to many
christians the ones who were speaking
the most about heaven and hell
seemed the least
uh affected by the hell on earth or the
suffering of people on earth yeah what
an interesting dichotomy i'd never
really thought about that before i mean
we're kind of seeing that in the
american political system right now the
bottom line is this and i think he said
it perfectly this is all conjecture like
what are we talking about none of us
knows what the hell we are talking about
but it's fun maybe the atheists are
right
keel over lights out that's it end of
story very well either way the story
that we have here on this planet
is pretty darn clear whether you're a
person of faith or not and that is to
uh alleviate as much suffering as we can
focus on this world not the next one i
love the three r's he referenced to
reconciliation restoration
and renewal
from the three kind of central
philosophers of the christian faith that
uh that felt really practical in a way
as well and look in the end
the answer is we don't know and maybe
the mystery is more important maybe the
the question is more important so dear
listeners
tell us what do you think happens when
we die are you uh a religious believer
do you believe in heaven and hell what
does heaven and hell even look like if
you're a christian we'd love to hear
from you too like uh do you think rob
has it wrong i think uh his philosophy
needs to be tweaked a little bit i mean
we didn't get into the into the
nitty-gritty of everything he believed
but we'd love to hear from you as well
ladies and gentlemen and people of all
gender persuasions and identities
welcome to metaphysical milkshakes
bonus conversation as you know sometimes
we love to bring fans on the show
uh you can write us on social media you
can leave a positive i hope apple
podcast review with your life's big
question
and we'd love to bring you on the show
and that is what we're doing right now
with mr aaron corney who uh has
apparently a life's big
question and we would love to hear from
you erin welcome to metaphysical
milkshake uh yeah thanks for having me
on guys uh you know i think a lot about
what we all do with our time during the
day and i'm often like hmm would i be
more productive if i had more time i
don't know if i would or not but i kind
of struggle a lot with like what would
we all do if we had eternal life what
would you guys do what should i do let's
let's pretend for a moment we could holy
[ __ ] i think about this all the time
here's the context under which i think
about this as i think about it in a
mostly like christian view of heaven
which is like it's eternal
it's only good there's clouds there's
harps there's
fun diversions
and you live forever there that's
always as a child it sounded like
torture
it's just like oh god
i don't want to have to experience that
like i hate harp music you master the
harp and then you master the bassoon and
the and the oboe and the double bass and
then and then the accordion so to me
like eternal life seems like a kind of
torture
which is why i think the only answer to
an afterlife let's suppose there is
we're not just kind of meat suits and we
die and our consciousness switches off
like a light switch but we progress into
another plane of of being that we have
to move into timelessness
where time is not this kind of
uh constraint on us that this plane is
beyond time and space because other any
other answer is like
it's horrible like i couldn't i i
couldn't live forever i would i mean i i
don't want it even thinking about it
right now like i'm getting high blood
pressure you really think about this in
spiritual terms i think about it fully
in material terms i like i always think
about like
you know like living forever on this
earth like vampire lestat or something
like
and what's funny is i my sort of primary
motivation for it
is uh curiosity like i just want to know
what happens next you know i just like i
want to know what happens next uh you
know it's it's like the same reason why
i can't go to sleep at night because i'm
like one more episode one more episode
one more episode
you know it's like it's midnight it's
time to go to sleep okay but just one
more episode and then i'm going to sleep
like i i can't help but think about life
that way where i'm like one more episode
until we have flying cars okay let's
just i wanna i wanna experience it i
wanna feel it this was a
very strong impulse in my younger years
and i'd like to say that you know
with old age i have matured somewhat
rain wow i now understand the value you
know of the time that we have on this
earth and i and i want to use you know
the time that i have in the best way and
and of course with my family you know
could you that's the that's the thing
they always say about like the
immortality like the curse of
immortality like can you see your your
family members grow old and die while
you remain young and incredibly handsome
forever
and i'm like
uh
[Music]
maybe
i no no you would do that no i know how
dare you suggest that i would do that
rain aaron what how does this uh
question keep you up at night what what
what provoked this you know the the uh
the idea of like
you know if he had immortality nothing
but time it seems like boredom and
depression are the two biggest villains
you have to you have to grapple with so
i would think about that right you know
at some point you run out of things to
do so
you know
uh you spend time with your close ones
and then when they're gone what do you
do with that you don't wanna get
depressed you only get bored so like
what is there to expand on so you gotta
find projects you gotta like think about
like
science and like how can you help with
long-term scientific research but i
actually was thinking about this before
uh getting to talk to you guys right now
and i actually think i would focus a lot
on like i know it's altruistic so we
have to see in practice if i get to do
this um
but getting to teach life lessons
because i think we see the biggest
problems happening of people who don't
want to
uh read history as much and study it as
much but there's always some
spokesperson so i think i'd become some
kind of shamanic guru who people would
listen to and i would try and use that
for good to teach lessons uh and and
take the you know using takeaways and
you know i don't know i volunteer you to
get your neck bitten and become vampire
lestat
aaron corny well that was the last thing
on my bucket list for this year is to
have you tell me that so thank you erin
thank you so much for uh coming on
metaphysical milkshake we i love the
fact that we we took care of one of your
bucket lists this is uh this is what we
do here i appreciate you know what i
take it all back if i had all of
eternity i'd spend it on this call with
you guys oh
that's sweet what about a podcast that
lasted
forever that that's called the joe rogan
experience
[Laughter]
thank you very much
good night everybody good night everyone
thanks aaron
so find us on social uh it's our
personal hell but we're happy to go
there for you at reza aslan find us in
the hell of social media that's right
at reza aslan and at rayne wilson we are
on twitter at
metamilkpodcast subscribe to
metaphysical milkshake we love you all
until next week love wins thank you to
our guest rob bell and hey by the way
check out his podcast the robcast
good idea
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tank it was produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
[Music]
robel my favorite episode this has been
my favorite episode
i wouldn't go that far
i'd seen it's in my top 15
of all
of all your episodes of all 15 of our
episodes this has been my definitely top
15.
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you